[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: If you're a
mobile app publisher,
you probably already
know that you
can earn revenue by showing
AdMob ads to your users.
But what you might not
know is that you can also
use AdMob to show your
ads to your users,
and that's done with
AdMob Campaigns.
A campaign is a
run of ads that you
create and configure to get
a portion of your total ad
traffic.
You determine the goals and
how many impressions to serve,
which ad units are targeted,
and-- the best part--
design your own creatives
in a bunch of formats,
including video.
So what are your goals?
Got a new app that you'd like
to promote and the ones you've
already launched?
Campaign for it.
Want to drive traffic from
your apps to your website?
Campaign for that.
Meet a sneaker tycoon
who loves your app
and wants to pay you directly
to advertise his dope,
remastered lows?
Make a campaign for it--
and then send me a pair.
I'm a size 12.
[MUSIC PLAYING]